you have to understand again even if you  are a kid man a doctor or was secretary  on the bench you have to understand the  game confidence is fundamental it's  fundamental and in this moment  everything goes goes against and the  players they they feel it I think it's  time to be a little bit honest and to  say clearly the referees are afraid to  give decisions for Chelsea I go home I  will find a set  I said family I will try to watch  another of the rugby  the team play more than enough to to win  the game create chances to win the game  the referee made an important mistake  but that's part of the game I know I  know one of my best qualities is is to  is to read the game for my players is to  read the opponent is to identify every  detail about the opponent and I feel  that my my work was was betrayed if I  can if he's the right the right word